adele is opening up about her confidante
and supporter drake the two have been
very vocal about their love and respect
for each other with drake recently
calling adele one of his best friends in
the world while promoting her latest
single easy army did you know they were
that close i i was shocked like
everybody else when when adele had first
said that and then drake sort of you
know threw his support behind like i i
oftentimes people say oh yeah they're
one of my friends but this to me seems
different then like really cool yeah
they're like close yeah and adele echo
both sentiments most recently appearing
on the spout podcast where she spoke
about how they have confided in each
other about their music after she
revealed drake heard 30 in its entirety
a year before its release
do you two normally give each other
advice or feedback before releasing
music
not always before releasing it was just
you know it we definitely spoke a bit
about it this time um because
you know releasing music during a global
pandemic is like no one's done it before
like you know so
um but we always yeah we always talk
about work stuff and you know get each
other's opinions on it and stuff like
that and it's um
it's one of the reasons i love being
friends with him is because being able
to like
have access to someone that really does
know you know a lot of what it's like
sort of you know to be you and stuff
like that and
he's also very like he decides
everything and it can be quite daunting
sometimes to be you know make sure that
you're across all of that stuff and
everything like that so um yes we
definitely have confided in each other
over like um well i've certainly
confided in him about like how i want to
do things do i think it's possible like
you know with the way that the world is
right now but his brain is absolutely
great because he also released an album
during the pandemic certified lover boy
did he send you that before he released
it oh no oh no no he didn't share the
whole thing with me no um
no but i i've heard a couple of snippets
of it and stuff like that but um i love
that record
yeah it's wild yeah but it makes sense
though like it does it does make sense
to me because they're both massive
superstars not necessarily that they're
massive they're they are sort of they
are within genres but a league of their
own within those genres and that sort of
you know who did you confide in i know
that you know drake obviously you know
he could turn to jay-z and now kanye and
everything else but sort of like in that
world of you are alone like you were so
large yeah you know you're so big that
you are you know almost so isolated from
even peers right that you they you know
it makes sense to me that they would
gravitate towards each other you know
somebody who gets it yeah she said
recently in a cbc radio interview that
she refers to uh drake and herself as a
dying breed because they became so big
before this massive explosion of social
media where you had to catch people's
attention within the first five seconds
the tick tocks and everything so she's
saying that they kind of grew up uh
idolizing all these musicians before all
that and then they kind of followed in
those footsteps and now it's a whole
other landscape but and the difference
being between drake and adele is drake
was one of the pioneers of tick tock
yeah was it really no but listen think
of the first tick tock trends you saw
car door open oh yeah right the dancing
all the parodies like drake is drake is
a meme machine when it comes to his
creatives where adele has sort of shied
away from things like tick tock where
anything drake does gets run through the
meme machine
so fast and i mean he you know he loves
it obviously that's true and it's
interesting too that she said you know
he makes all the decisions yeah and so
it's interesting to know at this point
in her career that yeah she's making her
own decisions but to do that there's a
lot of responsibility so she kind of
uses him as like uh you know somebody
that she can look up to and get advice
from so i love that nelson sang
vasario saying adele can be my friend
love her so much
she can be my friend i love her so much
mocha sang um i'm not surprised that
adele and drake are super close
uh and fellaini saying drake seems uh to
be needy and friendly with everyone wow
yeah i don't know i think drake is drake
he is a scorpio um okay so aj is saying
one of the uk's biggest stars and one of
canada's biggest stars being friends
makes sense to me not surprising really
i love scorpios i'm just saying